good morning everyone good morning
Millenia good morning Claudia hi guys
welcome back to episode 2 day 2 season 1
morning toast we're so excited to be
with you thank you for bearing with us
thank you for your patience we want to
make sure the quality is premium our
usual as always check and I are working
overtime around the clouds round the
clock to bring a premium high quality
content to our viewers which is not easy
no it's not easy but we do it for you
because we love you because we love the
toast and even with all of our troubles
yesterday number two overall in the
podcast or cast app like our pod is like
who is what's going on and there's a
problem because the Sun Sentinel which
is a florida-based magazine came out
with a podcast has been number one
strong and it took a noisy we have
what's the baloney is florida felonious
far de name you actually wanna i posted
on my story like this felonious lurid i
must be amazing because we can't crack
them and the girl messaged me she's like
oh my god I love the toast I work for
the sun-sentinel my two favorite podcast
that number one and two but this is the
thing they're on the home page of the
podcast right so I don't know if they're
number one because they're on the home
page or they're on the home page because
they're number one what is it um it's a
chicken and egg situation and it's
pissing me off and it's pissing me off
but you know what like number two I feel
like I feel like Tarun's
number two feels like first okay but it
doesn't because it's to really I feel
like you know it's too accessible and
you know it's due it's like Ricky Bobby
if you ain't first you're last it's so
dry shirt is so Ricky Bobby today it's
gigi hadid meets Ricky Bobby
it's she Jenny needs Tommy thought
Hilfiger me maybe Bobby yeah XR BAE
yeah so as always Jackie and I are here
to deliver the fast five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast or
a sip
whereas cheers Cheers I'm not drinking
right now my gosh so bad like yeah and
we have to be like we can't work on
we're we don't have the luxury yet of
like being truffle food but don't worry
we'll get there well casing of our firms
we took an Instagram poll and
overwhelmingly was at the
% yes for the ferns it's like totally um
How to Lose a Guy in 10 days this is our
baby this is our love fern but it's fake
so I can't die oh that's great so our
life fact I love Canada I love Hanna
I think I'm crow fern and they look
pretty nice do they can I say yeah a
little-little bush they look a little
weird but like I like it okay it's time
you know what this is a work in progress
I don't yet you've noticed so every day
there might be changes until we get it
right and you know what I believe it was
I think it was Gandhi yeah who said the
toast is only there we go up from here
stay [ __ ] tuned I think that was him
it might have been Barack Obama I'm not
sure either way not sure anyways today's
a great day because one is national
sibling day hello we are siblings people
don't even know that we're siblings like
everyone jegging Lenny other nerves
Jenny Dom in your room yes so [ __ ] me
there's no way people can even hear what
we just said why cuz one it didn't make
sense sure a saying Johnny I was just
gonna say we're just we've recapped ahem
Real Housewives of Atlanta like to
ourselves before and might later leave
my favorite part of the whole episode
was the first 10 seconds where Andy
asked as per usual
he won't lecture I get away with it how
she by Sheree is doing and her answer
was inaudibly joggers what what are we
dryers what's going on was she by Sheree
now ders yeah what I thought everyone
was like kandi was literally sitting
right next which was like what did you
say Duggars she wasn't speaking English
by style will recap Housewives later and
the under pump rules and if we have time
then like Jersey Shore and everything
else we promised you yesterday and it's
also equal pay day oh my god I can't
believe it's equal pay day
it's 2018 do you know what I mean yeah
it's like obviously it's equal pay day
pay should be equal yeah
justice for the women who are not being
paid equal or not being paid at all
that's good you know it's just like it's
annoying like I'm done with it yeah see
I forgot to wear red I'm wearing like a
pink cuz red it's actually just a you
know women are smarter than men
everyone's supposed to be wearing red
just to be analogous with the fact that
we are in the red layer below the pay
level like that's so small I'm ready
because my hair and your and your shirt
is red and I have a red shape also
Olivia didn't tell me like soon enough
in the day that it was equal pay day or
else I would have worn red actually I
don't think I own one red item of
clothing well I might have worn these
pants with the red stripe but these are
my pants with the white stripe except I
couldn't because this is so Mehra thing
but they're made from like garbage
garbage yep and these ones shoot so I
have them in red and have them in white
and every time I wear either of them
they rip they split between legs and I'm
not even like doing the splits you know
I just honestly I think it's so funny
like what you're wearing today like a
person who wears self it does not wear
the outfit you are yes here's the thing
style is just so eclectic it's so
eclectic it's so unexpected and you know
what it's a little bit like it's Erika
Jayne in the sense it like yesterday was
our first day back and like I was
dressing for the job I have another job
I want and like that was my first day
back morning show host look now this is
my second day web show host look you
know like we just do a web show
I'm wearing leggings I'm gonna go iCarly
okay and I was like I don't know if
that's like my own thing but like Carly
is like so watch out and honestly I feel
like nobody talks about how we rounded
Cosgrove was like the first influence
our icarly web show
Hoda Lee and like we're inspired by
icarly on the regular yeah except for
like the whole dead shrine or pedophilia
thing right what I can't get over I
can't get over we posted some creepy-ass
pictures to all these pictures on Google
all the girls in the pictures are crying
I like its guttural and how painful the
truest form oh it's the definition of a
pit like if you're like hey I've never
had a pit how do I get one go look at
those photos of Dan Schneider and
younger oh it's like hey look I'm really
the mood for a pit a what should I do
- Ann Schneider Google yeah reddit 4chan
oh my god
speaking of Nickelodeon do you know that
I'm Drake Bell had some new DS release I
did but you know what I don't I don't
I'm not I don't indulge in that okay so
to get them of course it's such an
invasion of IBM but obviously anytime a
celebrity gets new pictures I have to go
look at it and it's important it's like
harder to find them you would think yeah
which is a good thing yes
Twitter's where it's at but I couldn't
find the
video I saw some pictures on Twitter but
I wanted to see the video and apparently
like 4chan it's like where it goes down
I will never search my name in portent I
can only imagine what they say yeah
4chan it's like the most unregulated
it's like Reddit on a next level it's
like it's evil yeah yeah and a lot of
the celebrity like hacks start on 4chan
it's literally the oldest website ever I
couldn't figure out how to search Drake
Bell so I didn't find it but I did see
Drake Bell's penis and honestly it seems
like it's enormous
how did the pictures get leaked um I
don't know
and if I just stand how that works like
just lock your phone you know no it's
not that easy and just wait till you
know it happens to you oh my god totally
oughta take new tees are you nuts
oh that's true I don't know I what is
such an invasion of privacy that it's
like yes of course I would love to see
like yeah but I just I won't do it I
don't want to contribute to the culture
no first that makes nude photos
acceptable okay whatever it's taking
like a moral high ground so early in the
morning I mean it's very a moral
whatever you know what it's like this is
the world we live in
it's very sad it is no it's so sad
especially when it happens to like good
people yeah but I don't take nudies but
like it just depends on the level of
like a spine FBI's doing because if the
FBI is every time I open myself check
camera like do they have access to that
without actually taking a picture not
even that what about just your camera my
webcam you're just your camera yeah like
on your phone it could be on at all time
because I will take pictures but I
sometimes like a look at my boobs like
in the camera but don't take a picture
but it's like yes sometimes like my
phone is facing me yeah I don't give the
FBI any idea totally
the FBI's everywhere they're totally in
this room hi
bring us a snack I am hungry I keep
forgetting to eat before the show I know
because I'm just like so motivated to
make remember like waking up so early
and I don't know there's something about
being up like before the Sun that makes
me not hungry do you know what time the
Sun comes up cuz you're definitely not
up before him yes I am okay let's come
into the Best Buy let's jump into the
facts out cuz we actually have like such
great stories today that are not like
you know world-changing but they're not
boring and like we're not gonna skip
over any so I'm excited first app Rachel
McAdams has welcome to her a child she's
so secretive
she is so secretive but those were her
accorded that she was pregnant but I
don't even remember me yeah on the on
the old
speculation like I don't think you
confirmed right and this is exactly what
I was saying yesterday the most
successful couples are the ones that are
quiet like Rachel McAdams probably is an
amazing marriage an amazing family
because she's not up our asses on
Instagram about it and last night I went
to the movies and I saw blockers which
was unbelievable and it looks like the
worst movie and I was thinking about our
conversation about Channing and Tatum I
mean honey hitting in Jenna uh-huh like
and I was singing Judd Apatow and Leslie
Mann or one of those couples that are
successful because they're not so public
but the public has catapulted them into
like being yester but they don't get
into it no they don't
the public catapulted Channing in Jenna
and the catapult Chrissy and John and
they give in to it and they like to all
the instagrams like Leslie and Judd just
probably have the best life like just so
much money and like just like they could
be work when they want to you know yeah
but then like he puts her in all of his
movies and they work together a big huge
people on camera like an ironic and the
same thing she did speech anyone in this
movie I was thinking the same thing
also because I was kind of confused
because it was Leslie Mann and then it
was John Cena who was also in trainwreck
which is a jet Apatow movie and I was
thinking this must be a jet Apatow movie
but it wasn't it was a Seth Rogen movie
I feel like it's on it's all the same
it's all freak singing it's all
pineapple Express which started out
freaks and geeks it is it was such a
good movie let me tell you why first of
all I I'm like so cynical cuz I think
I'm like the funniest person ever I'm
not like the breath I mean the toast is
the funny show ever like nothing could
be funnier than this so when I go like
to watch other TV shows like I'm like oh
it's not as funny as our show same with
like other movies oh my god I had tears
in my eyes I was laughing so hard I
never laugh at movie it's like I'm been
left and everything I left it nothing it
was so funny you weirdly laugh at a lot
Jackie Leslie man was amazing like I
heard you laughing at scenes from Jersey
Shore like when you were watching at
home yeah of course it's literally the
funniest show of all time I didn't laugh
that many times no not the New Jersey
Shore I didn't laugh at the nutrition no
I think really well I'm watching old I'm
a season four wait let me just finish
why you talked about the New Jersey
Shore yeah let me tell you why I feel
it's a really important movie for
coming-of-age women to see and then
first of all it just it's an important
conversation about sex cuz like I feel
like it's always being like shoved down
our throats in this culture and it was
kind of like nice that like all these
girls like wanted to have sex but then
like a lot of them didn't end up doing
it because I just didn't want to don't
gave away no that's at the point
no that literally is the point also you
find this out very earlier I'm one of
the characters in the closet she's
lesbian and I just think the way she
comes out it's like I literally had
tears in my eyes was please do the
ruining the movie I don't care it was so
good it's such an important
coming-of-age movie I think everyone
should see it okay I'll go see it if you
stop ruining it Oh Tina oh my god
amazing he's so funny and his thighs are
in it like so many times in his thighs
or huge but not looking at that way
they're gonna muscular like tree trunk
kind of way he plays like an
overprotective dad it was he's such a
good actor like he is what the rock is
gonna be for comedy like The Rock went
down like the action because he was also
w tonight so he's like the action Kevin
Hart a man action do your own stunts
action bronson chin you know I love that
and John Cena is going the comedy round
and he's so funny and I was thinking
also because he has a wife in the movie
that he's kissing his wife and like what
it's Nikki Bella thing Nikki Bella is
probably freaking out yeah because I
feel like she's already insecure like
always ready to fight someone except I'm
obsessed with them um saying I'm
obsessed with her same she's gorgeous
this next story I'm obsessed with in it
gives us a vessel which you know how we
feel about that that's so weird of you
like between your culottes and your
vessel yesterday like were you okay
um you know what I was just trying to
take this whole thing seriously yeah and
I'm obviously not everyone this jacket
um like literally every day for the past
three years but Bethenny Frankel says
she once went on a date with Megan
Markos ex-husband Trevor engleson by the
way this headline is fake news and Beth
Mia
tweeted herself no we didn't we just met
but don't let that get in the way don't
listen to get in the way of a good story
I love her I love her she said on the
Kyle and Jackie O show are you Kyle no
it's just like no it's crazy that
there's like two Jackie O's with like
web shows but we're like totally on
opposite ends they're Australian radio
show host and awesome my favorite thing
about Jackie was like yeah I know
they're like this is my god-given birth
name yeah people are like you know
you're not the real Jackie O blah blah
but like about Jackie Kennedy like and
they try and shame me like you don't
call yourself Jackie I'm like that's my
[ __ ] name yeah but if one person it
was like you're not the real Jackie O
she's in Australia like that's the real
Jackie oh that's funny
so members I like get tags and stuff
that's obviously meant for the other
takeo and it's just nice I wonder if she
gets tagging stuff yeah she's probably
cross what's her Instagram um probably
like the real Jack who lives at Jackie O
like no Kennedys no a Rando that's so
annoying so every quarter every quarter
I message her who's like a wonderful
life knock on wood like you don't need
the problem stop but then it's like then
I'm girls no problems and then problems
will find oh you totally once you like
act like you're like this perfect that
literally happen to us and like you've
ever acted that way about it and I don't
think that I acted that way I have like
more pits than I know what to do it hold
it you know he's with so many pets
literally two years ago I started
getting such rapid that like I thought I
had like a stomach ulcer and I actually
went to the hospital it was just like
any time when she that cost you the
hospital millions of dollars so
expensive I read an article that
Millennials are taking ubers to the
hospital instead of ambulances because
ambulance when you get like if you don't
have insurance it's like $3,000 oh my
goodness I did I took an uber it was
your the middle of the night in the
maneuver Holden really not uh not like
704 anyone I don't think so we've called
the police together when we got exposed
to on Washington yeah which way you know
what these days I'm so on face I was
walking in Chelsea and a man was peeing
on the street and I was like yeah no
it's nothing it's nothing New York
lawless society lawlessness lawlessness
thing you know what I'm done trying to
be like a citizen of the world
I'm I'm done trying to be like an
upright citizen in this in the society
your job right citizen down well are you
done trying to join The Upright Citizens
Brigade by the way I was absolutely
gonna say that when I said upright
citizens it's actually like a very
successful like a lot of her speeches
like if you can get in there like a big
deal and then I think you might have an
SNL yeah or like something amazing yeah
which is pretty cool yeah um we keep
thinking good morning yeah we absolutely
have to explain like okay so one of the
past month while we were trying to think
of new names for the show we thought of
everything if you thought it we thought
it we have a laundry list of names they
were all pretty terrible they were all
pretty terrible some better than others
some you know we're like the morning
blank like whatever and some were just
out of the box thinking and one of those
names which I'm sure someone will now
trademarking take is probably yeah
here we are to ruin it is good morning
Millennials because maybe we just
thought it was cute like the reason why
I think everyone like loved our show is
because like it's a millennial Mashhadi
a morning show like if you turn on any
like cable network you will not find
anything similar to us but you find like
mid-morning programming you don't find
morning shows 9:30 not even that like
just like the talent it's like the
youngest person in daytime television is
Meghan McCain right like they need to be
doing a better job right it's not
catered towards like our audience right
I feel represented in daytime television
do you or at morning television
yeah no I think it's a scene except
every time I watch like Kelly Ripa I'm
like I like her yeah because she like
pops around and she was wearing
self-portrait yeah and she really has
like a great energy she has the exact
energy that you need in the morning yeah
anyway so we were like this is the
Millennial morning show how about good
morning millennium at first we thought
it was [ __ ] genius
no some people thought it was genius
some people didn't like it personally I
don't like the term Millennials I know
that Millennials don't even like being
caught yes that's true now we're gonna
like start perpetuating the term
Millennials when like everybody hates
that word so we were really and then
then put the nail in the coffin he was
like honestly
good morning Millennials like what
someone but what an igloo fo landed what
an alien would say if he came to earth
good morning that heals everything she
said that like we couldn't take the name
seriously and like we can't say the word
good morning without saying we're
playing charades and literally every
time cuz once something's funny it's a
joke that I just have to murder murder
every time this is every time I would
have the opportunity to go this would be
me okay you wanna play yes TV show sort
of three words good morning I hope other
people think this is funny not just us
we were loving so last night in bed I
was like thinking we have to tell the
story because we teased it yesterday
and then I'm like people aren't gonna
think this is funny and as I'm thinking
I'm laughing in my bed
good morning news honestly we need to
make a segment like an early morning we
need to do something with GMM and we
need Ben to come on and say
and when the bed doesn't it's just funny
here because he's like oh you can
tagging good morning anyway back to
Bethenny Frankel back to Anthony Franco
and the Megan Marco of it all because
okay so everything in this world just
comes back to my DiMarco the post
widened its I have the most royal fever
right now I've never had it as I told
you I finished watching the crown and
that just catapulted me into watching
like all of these documentaries on the
Windsors and I'm obsessed with them and
I just can't believe this is happening
no and now I understand what you're
saying how good leg deal it is how big
of a deal it is that she's a divorced
woman like and that she's biracial yeah
that's the biggest deal ever like they
are just like they have like the whitest
blood ever mm-hmm and now it's just like
Megan markle's she's here and I love it
and it just a it just shows how much the
palace has changed my family has as much
as I love love love love love to make
fun of Megan Marco like I think what
she's doing is important and like I
didn't one thing on my Instagram story
about how like she really does like need
a new stylist she looks so bad and I
always felt bad saying like that you
know her hemline was you know too short
or too long for her coat and all this
stuff but what Gary Jannetty does like I
feel and then all the celebrities that
like it you know and comment on it like
Lisa Rinna is obsessed with it and that
just makes me feel better like okay I'm
not the only person who agrees that like
she needs a tailor so is that my
instagram story and like honestly like
for every like joke that I make I would
say like 10% it's like you through me
and Billy 90% is like lol but really
people came after me like people are
like really protective of our princess
well it's not our princess well she is
our princess because she's the first
American wasn't she's Canadian
no her show was filming oh it's very
confusing I thought she was Canadian too
and that the Americans were taking
credit for her but that's so us no but
someone actually in our morning toasters
Facebook group just found clip she was
in she was a FedEx girl and horrible
ball so I already knew that I didn't
know that I know of all of her I know or
things are coming out here see toes
commercial Jackie her toes to you this
commercial that picture of her dad
honestly that made my heart like sink
when you look up the definition of pure
in the dictionary just pure like yeah
pure pure it's a picture of Megan Mark
dad sitting in the club you shop and
Starbucks called images of Britain cause
he's trying to learn about its daughters
who culture and he's gonna walk her down
the aisle and like he's gonna recognize
the aisle from the pub we are totally
doing a lot of show during the the Royal
Wedding it goes but because of the time
difference it'll be like 4:00 in the
morning but I don't care so we just
won't sleep we'll go out when I was in
high school
Kate and William got married and like
they are just the true definition of
just like everything goes because
they're really gonna be king and queen
or however [ __ ] works on her
understand and I was up all night I
bought like all the special edition
magazines like that was just so epic I
can't believe we got to live through
that and and we're gonna get to live
through this I just I can't believe that
I wasn't really me go to London that I
wasn't in tune with it I think we should
in May is that one of those it's gonna
be so crazy I know but we're not the
only people who have this idea and then
we're gonna skate outside web show no I
would love to but I'd love to just go
like when it's quieter I just you know
also you never get like a premium
experience they watching in person you
need to watch fun TV we could barely do
Coachella you think we're gonna do the
Royal Wedding yes coach tells us weekend
and Jack and I are not going you know we
went last year literally for you guys we
didn't go from we went to go all the
party thing at the scoop and we did and
honestly there was very little to no
scoop mm-hmm and I'm just not putting
myself through that again I'm sorry like
I love the toasters so much but not that
much
maybe next year but this year just for a
million reasons it's not work it's for
that reason we're out but maybe next
year I don't know yeah um for Oh also
William and Kate becoming king and queen
like how do you feel about Prince
Charles the dad mm-hmm
so um I think like I'm like do you think
it's possible to skip over him yes the
Queen could you ever see why everyone
thinks that they are going to skip over
Haley because he's like really old and
like even though that literally these
people don't die no because they have
the best medicine in the world and look
I don't know just British people are
like like Jewish people have like
problems health right like British
people are fine except for their teeth
sorry to all the British papers oh he's
being very mumbly Oh am i yeah really
yeah okay sorry I'm just sensitive to
because I know the body brush red sheep
I should wear people saying those be no
no but just yesterday we were talking so
because we're so excited that it just
got a little muffled I do think they're
gonna skip Charles a because he's like
kind of disgraced in the sense of
getting divorced
as a royal is like the craziest thing
you can do and marrying a divorce day
and it was just so much again dog Diana
I like I don't think they want that
they're so sensitive he's in his old age
I think just like let him retire he
doesn't give me like struggle leader
vibes either
yeah William and his receding hairline
like definitely give me like strong
leadership qualities yeah also but then
I started looking into it I'm like is it
possible and all these websites said no
it's not possible
plus like William might not want to be
king yet so I think life is oh yeah
or does it just begin also yeah and I
love the Queen and there's a major she
got so much [ __ ] like when in her
formative years for not being like yeah
in the crown like that she's not like
that why not for cool enough her she did
get her hair done by Vidal Sassoon and
like Jackie I was being an auditor after
watching Real Housewives of Beverly
Hills last season I don't think anyone
should own now any of the suits under C
am i that Queen didn't get her hair but
when I hang out at Eden whatever it was
um and she just has come to epitomize
like what royalty is know and there's a
lot of speculation about Prince Phillip
now because he has fallen ill and he's
hit so old I know I may had to stop it
so sad
no it's so crazy I have like people like
famous people died you know and how like
her mortality is just like always up for
debate because of we're just talking
about with like ladies I'm gonna be is
well gonna be king when she dies like
right it's so sad and I love and I bet
like a lot of people are like looking
forward to her dying I don't know why I
like so they can get like a promotion or
something and like I'm sure it'll be
good for the economy which is just so
sad because then like there's a
coronation I can't in the shadow and I
[ __ ] love worked and I went and I
wanted to say Oh in the crown like the
royal family is always under threat of
like being abolished because they're
like you know kind of backward you don't
when they're needed to modernize and do
the country need it do you feel like now
the Royal fat like it could stay like I
feel like they'll never go away nor
should they well because now they're
totally separate like they have no
influence on like government or policy I
mean I know literally nothing but from
what I gather is like there's the
Parliament like that's like the real
people and then they're just like a
tourist attraction yeah
and they're the Church of England yeah
but the separation of church and state
like they don't have any excellence I'm
like politics they just there's like
your heads but so did I they're like
socialites like they go to other
countries I make nice but does that make
you think that maybe one day like there
is no need for it it makes me sound too
new but there's there's no need for it
now and they're still around so they'll
be around forever and also like I hope
they can do with the palace if there's
no why don't we have a royalty would you
know the Kardashians
Claudia Jackie oh that's true yeah that
was the boost I needed okay we've been
like circling the drain on the story
like what else so the story is that
there's no story because Bethany and the
ex-husband just have only met and they
just want to start some [ __ ] they want
to start some stuff okay whatever moving
on
Khloe Kardashian is producing a show
about murderous sisters and we are just
so excited to be at the helm of this
totally but you know what if we learned
anything from kocktails with khloé' it's
like Khloe's you just stick to like
doing other things besides like getting
involved in programming that's not
Keeping Up with the Kardashians if we
learned anything from kocktails with
khloé'
don't get your hopes up Khloe Kardashian
is producing a new true crime TV series
about murderous sisters well this
unclear what exactly inspired Khloe's
interests and sisters who kill each
other oh I wonder what inspired her I
heard she watched the morning toast okay
or conspire to kill others page six TV
revealed that the Kardashian sibling
will executive produce a new TV series
for Investigation Discovery to premiere
in 2019 I'm sorry I can't stop looking
at my highlights on flagrant we look
fabulous
yes per usual for you sorry I missed
that whole thing what channels are gonna
be on Investigation Discovery oh that's
a good channel as you would think I just
wonder what her involvement it's like
everybody sees is like a producer like
are they in the back with a pair of
headphones sitting on an Apple box like
being helpful are they in their house
you know I don't know I'm Kyle Richards
like really blurs the line because like
she had it in the back with a pair of
head but I think it's because she's
filming yeah you know what I mean I was
love to like get her on and like I have
so many thoughts for Kyle Richards like
why I would love to have a Kenan
interview with her like really about
like everything what's everything I
don't think she knows the power that she
has she could really like revitalize the
entire Real Housewives of Beverly Hills
franchise if she turns on Lisa
Vanderpump well here's the thing I was
thinking about it all Real Housewives
franchise
I think they I'm sure that they want to
do this but they always have at least
one who's been there since the first
season me Vicki Gunvalson all the New
York ones well
Ramona and who are we just talking about
Lisa Vanderpump and Kyle Richards nipa
Kyle
Kyle's there from the beginning but she
doesn't she has totally modernized like
to me she seems like a new housewife she
took a new house she haircut she's like
the Royal House of Windsor she has
modernized she's modernized she's like
sure some reason she doesn't give me the
Lisa Vanderpump Nene Vicki Gunvalson and
Ramona vibe and that's almost a good
thing because they're so bright they
think because they've been since the
beginning they can do whatever they want
they're manipulative they're friends
with the producers or friends of Andy
like they think that their position in
the show is secure so they could really
do whatever they want and be mean to
everyone Kyle doesn't give me that vibe
at all I honestly didn't even realize
until right now that her and they said
been on this show for the same amount of
time yeah because she doesn't give off
that vibe maybe it's also because she's
younger all those ladies are like almost
60 so like they give off this like old
wisely that she embraces the new people
and she gets in it laya Lisa Vanderpump
tries to stay above it but really she
doesn't know she is below no yes no
she's just above it but she's really a
design the most pertinent thing that has
ever been said I'm so important to this
solution Erika Jayne said it like her
first week of Housewives remaining Lisa
Vanderpump what she knew what was that
that's why she's just so brilliant we
need to bring back Eileen Davidson I
think I can you love her and also you
know I'm like itching for a little bit
just because like Beverly Hills needs
ladies let me think and because like
Lisa Rinna is no longer bringing the
spice which I completely understand and
we'll get to that in a little bit yeah
HOSA okay I just Carlton really yeah
Brandi tweeted yesterday I had an
amazing day with Andy Cohen what does
that mean like I think Lisa Vanderpump
would die I don't know if Brandi came
back with Lisa Vanderpump 100% money
Lisa's not coming back and that's why
they went out to France he doesn't need
the show they had to beg her and pear a
million dollars a promise to promote
Vanderpump dogs this season in order to
get her to even agree to it she doesn't
need it
she's rich enough B she's famous stuff
and see she has man of her pearls so
she'll always be on Bravo yeah but they
begged her because they think that we
that we need her we don't need her and
literally don't need her and I mean I
feel like her house smells like true
like [ __ ] and yeah cuz like Co poops in
your house like or no pees in your house
maybe like once a day yeah and like it's
it's detrimental
yeah but if her house has so many
windows that they're always open I feel
like it like airs it out
think so ideally she gives me dirty
housewives and I feel like even though
her parties look so nice it's like
that's I feel like her dishes are not
clean yeah also that cream cup that she
gave um sorry
she's such a stuff starter no not even
that like that couple I feel like I'll
stick I feel like I'm on that orbit
commercial well she's a stuff starter
because I can't say [ __ ] yeah um this
next story
you're gonna love no I know I have mixed
feelings about it let me tell you why
the in Lea Michele and Darren Criss
announced adjoint tour so I love Lea
Michele and I love Darren Criss I can
not name one song either of them saying
and like if they want to go in towards
singing on Glee cannonball right oh yeah
like a cutter oh look I just want it now
you haven't sang yet I know and that
goes in here's really good that was
really good you want to take it from the
top I don't know the rest of the song I
know but like if they want to go on tour
and like sing songs from Glee like I
would be down like or just regular songs
but I'm not like a big fan of either of
their like personal albums yeah so I
don't know if I would necessarily buy
tickets them like maybe if I got these
for free I would go maybe it's like a
covers tour but the reason I'm so glad
that you brought this up Oh Claudia what
duel will perform together as well as
individually revisiting songs from
Broadway and Glee as well as performing
original songs from their recent solo
okay so look I'll enjoy like 20% yeah at
the job but this is the thing I'm glad
we brought up this story because it
leads me to a very impertinent
you know pertinent it's Jack yeah is
during our break I like fell down a
rabbit hole just like social media
whatever I'm and in our morning toasters
Facebook group someone suggested this
link that I watch there's this podcast
called I'll google it but in the
meantime iam sure they still illiterate
yeah and they have two hosts who are
both so funny and they had this
conspiracy theory that they like sat on
for a while they did some research and
then they realized that this conspiracy
theory very well could be true and they
did about like a 50 minute livestream on
their Facebook page proving the theory
that Lea Michele is illiterate and she
doesn't know how to write or read and
that Ryan Murphy is involved in this and
he knows her secret that he's the
notorious for keeping secrets so he
holds her secret and that's why they
keep working
together this conspiracy they took
pictures over the years videos over the
years it is so funny they went to her
social media they dissected all of her
captions they have all these thing one
more thing podcast oh my god go find the
livestream it's 50 minutes long I
watched the entire thing it's first of
all these two people like the hosts are
just like funny people they're like us
like it was just enjoyable to watch
but like the lengths they went they had
this like a little TV and they had like
a PowerPoint slide show it was so funny
I really encourage everyone to watch at
oh man did you watch it
um I watched a little bit but I had
already read like the recaps of I wasn't
well the computer Theory got so much
that she respond she responded to it
like with a message she's so funny her
met her all of her Instagram captions
are emojis and that she probably someone
writing it for her you know it's just
like the jonathan groff didn't we're
like he wrote ILY SFM on their on their
caption she just wrote on her caption
spelled out i love you so [ __ ] much
like io is FM like with an emoji like
it's really funny i don't think it's
true but like it's so funny i just think
everyone's watching that's so funny
speaking of conspiracy theories the one
where Shay Mitchell doesn't actually
travel and just post pictures from
Google okay so I saw he uses Instagram
they said there was something shady
going on with I read the investigation
okay with Shay Mitchell I clicked the
link in news his bio and they gave me no
information this is what happen I had to
click their source from style caster who
originally and that was wholly
informative so basically she posted like
a scenic picture in one of her travel
but she's like a now she's becoming like
a travel influencer she calls her things
a shake a she and it's like really cute
branding she takes a lot of travel
photos he took why this is important
yeah and in one of her Instagram stories
in the bottom corner there's a there's a
mouse like a computer mouse with the
arrow so they did a reverse google image
search and found the original photo that
she clearly cropped and filtered and it
looks different but the stars in the sky
are the same the laundry hanging on the
terraces of the building is the same the
cloud patterns are the same so she
clearly posted a picture that she got
from Google and then this cat made them
reverse google image search a bunch of
her other tribal photos that she's not
in and a lot of them are from other
Instagram profiles and Google but can I
say something that got article here's
the thing I was so mean-spirited whoever
wrote that article
like obviously hates Shay Mitchell for
some reason I don't know why and it was
the meanest article I ever read like to
show kind of sending and honestly the
more I think about it like efforts I'm
like that's like a weird thing for her
to do but then later like it's like I
don't think it's a big deal
I don't think it's a big deal either and
she really is in those places but maybe
like one night she didn't go out and
like she could her job is to like be
being inspirational and the only prop
sitting in bed eating pizzas not
inspirational so here where is Hong Kong
the night sky but the only problem is
that she should be giving photo credit
that's the only problem I see with this
thing
I agree because she is like a big photo
platform like it would be nice of her
but like I think that article whoever
wrote it like it's such a mean article I
was thinking like holy [ __ ] it's like
it's just thing really just want to
embarrass her yeah and like if you do a
deep dive into anyone's Instagram like
you'll find so much embarrassing [ __ ]
whether it's like Photoshop or photo
whatever like it was if you're looking
to buy and sort of you fight so much
about things yet Photoshop face to like
I just thought it was such a
mean-spirited article I'm like the tone
of the articles so rude
yeah my style cast her I don't know I
don't care and Shay Mitchell is in those
places if she was she was right if she
was home if she was in her labor
attending like she's in Hong Kong that
would be that shady but if we know she's
there and she just like posted a photo
that she didn't take like I don't think
that's a big deal no I don't think it's
a big deal and also like she's not a
professional photographer like she's not
I don't expect her like go to these
places with her like Canon DSLR and be
taking pictures of the night sky what's
a Canon DSLR camera is it a good one I
think she probably okay anyways this
final story before we go into TV show
recaps actually this is a TV show recap
sort of Paris Hilton is asking fans if
the symbol I should return after her
reunion with Nicole Richie which was so
cute and Lisa didn't happen sooner they
look both so genuinely happy to see each
other and it's like they used to laugh
so much together so no sauce on
assembling no matter how much you
dislike someone that never goes away no
never and honestly they just embraced
each other I forget they were at some
event they're like Fashion Awards la
CFDA something like the CFT le front row
daily front row which is CFDA of Los
Angeles that is it I don't know give me
those [ __ ] oh okay so you're just lying
they embraced each other it looks so
genuine and warm and like a photographer
just happened to be catching it I love
both of them
and together that like they wouldn't do
it cuz like Nicole Richie is like a
serious businesswoman with House of
Harlow she has kids like she need not be
going to like Cash's house and learning
about the cow but we can appreciate like
what that was I just I think this is an
important conversation to start about
like the inability for us regular people
to be able to watch Tippa life it's
literally nowhere it's only on Amazon
and you have to buy it you can you buy
it on iTunes itunes has actually
everyone was like who is everything
Amazon does everything no iTunes has
everything you know but it actually
doesn't have to buy every single thing
yeah so it's always a last resort for me
but like if you want something that
badly put money in to it good night look
at this here's the thing can I fern I
want to vote in her poll and saying no
do not bring it back one don't ruin a
good thing to like I'm sick of these
reboots it's like come up with an
original idea like where are the next
two socialites Germany who can embarrass
themselves on television it's totally
ours where are the next two socialites
you can embarrass themselves on
television again no it's like
embarrassing how like all the premium
content these days is re and it's barely
English except for queer eye which is
premium yeah but so ok queer I mean
girls on Broadway roseann willing grace
they're bringing back that Murphy Brown
they're bringing back fresh prints with
fresh princess yes baby Raven - OH Meets
World
it's like have we no good fuller house
fuller house everything on Netflix is
Arrested Development hot American summer
have we no good ideas anymore no I mean
we clearly don't
except for this yeah of course shaving
people for doing the exact thing that we
are doing no but like I'm down very
simple like ah I'm not down for a simile
reboot with two new people give it a new
name scene concept but don't call it a
reboot because then it's just gonna pale
in comparison just come back and don't
call that a reboot thank you you can all
to come back if you want yeah cuz we did
come back technically okay we are good
on time right whatever you cap
Vanderpump rules first okay
I was getting so pissed off watching
like these past few episodes because
like it was all over miscommunication
and like mad yesterday
mr. nation communication like it is not
a storyline make like they have the
footage roll the tapes when you don't
have
the footage like we don't have the
footage of Kristen and James together so
like yeah we can all fight about what
might have happened but I miss
Commission I waited till you finish no
but I could see if you knew the long no
okay
totally these are my thoughts on the
holes on everyone's pissing me off
especially Jax like I absolutely love
Jax but like but you know who's really
pissed me off even more is Lisa
Vanderpump it's like every 20 minutes in
the show it's like the obligation to put
Lisa Vanderpump in the shell like I
don't care about Tom Tom I don't care by
that Howard those scenes she's so boring
and the only thing more boring than
Lizaveta bump is Ken they're so boring
like I don't want to pick out plates I
merely want to do it for my own
apartment I don't want to do a free
restaurant that's taking way too long to
open yeah either way okay
people don't own restaurants overnight
especially for such a restaurant or like
her she should be taken over a year it's
still an open I really need to talk
about Raquel okay I'm scared okay so
like I'm always afraid to like say
things about the matter from pearls cask
was like we know a bunch of them and
like I don't want to be mean because
like they're really nice like but I
think also like a lot of what they do on
the show I'm able to separate the person
from the show I really am because like I
think sometimes they make the best
decision for the show and they're not a
true reflection of like who they are and
if I'm nice to say things about people
that like you know right
hi I don't know her Kelly I don't plan
on knowing her a lot it was her and said
like but yeah she and I trust Lala yeah
so I don't want to know Raquel so I
don't care she's literally so dumb and
annoying I can't stand her and the fact
that she's in the opening credits and
that she's in like the big picture pan
and that she's getting like a role is
really pissing no but the big picture
pan is always the ancillary characters
as well thanks Jeremy
jessamy on to Montana who's that he's
like blond he's worked there forever and
he's Jesse he's hunter scheana has a
kinda blonde hair I think and whatever
um Kristina Kelly yeah she's the worst
um no I agree I like but I also like
Raquel because who else is gonna date
James but I'm like did someone put up
with his stuff because if he's not
dating someone he'll be so [ __ ]
annoying and had it was like a really
nice guy and I was reminded of something
like Carson is that a boyfriend say who
Carter Carter Carter Carter yeah I'm
gonna get everything he said like the
way he reacted
her saying that there are these rumors
was the perfect action it wasn't like he
wasn't being a doormat yeah and he
wasn't being overly aggressive in rude
but that's why I like adjacent to Raquel
and James she was just like one hour
like that's why I was like oh I hate her
but let me say something that I forgot
oh and also James being like my girl's
going to be Miss USA don't say that
she's literally like Miss Sonoma County
like relax she's not even if she was
like surrounds to get to as she wanted
to Miss America and that's implying and
she would win all of them and USA is do
they ask questions I don't know she
would and grab um be like I'm being that
girl yeah like remember when that girl
got ass and she supports gay marriage
and like she let her got her title taken
away cuz she said no no she would be
that girl who they asked like she she
ography be taught in the schools and
then she was like you guys oh my god
what'd she say everything someone will
comment in the clip oh yeah oh my god
it's so funny it's like the most it was
answer she actually became famous after
that and at the time there was an MTV
show about all the pageant winners like
Miss Teen USA Miss USA and other SI
living together and that girl became so
famous from her dumb answer that she was
like going on press tours with them and
the winner was so mad cuz she's she's
getting all this fame for being an idiot
yeah I don't remember she was like like
the America's such as oh the Iraq and
everywhere such a well I can't believe
you don't know it I think the only one I
knew was that girl who said she did
support gay marriage and she literally
got her title tripped oh yeah oh my
goodness
that's like okay Kenny Moore I think the
only reason why these pageants are still
like pertinent in this name and Steve
Harvey yeah and it's just it's actually
shocking know that like pageant queens
don't become more famous because we live
in such like a vain shallow world that
like these girls are just waiting for
like being pretty like and like skinny
you would think that they would like get
us so many Instagram followers like they
don't first saw Olivia Koeppel she's but
she's like the exception like it's so I
agree up in Medway she really didn't
become famous because of right I
freaking famous because she was really
pretty and like an Instagram model
indeed a Nick Jonas I agree
and he's like a smart businesswoman and
she has been branding herself from the
day she was young and she plays each
other and she is awesome
but yes we live in a vain and shallow
world but we're now living in a time
where it's like that's not acceptable
anymore right so that's why these
patents are really outdated they really
are but then we get these moments like
the Iraq but it's a pen and everywhere
such a wrong one is the one where you
have to have a talent and you have to be
smart and like you were to college and
you have a cause Vanessa Williams yeah
and Kenny Moore yeah and like that's
cool she managed one letter that's
America Missa and then when she got
called Miss USA in the first season she
was like so offended a little too
offended because like it's just a
slip-up literally nobody
I don't it wasn't like a slight like no
one's and nobody does have a purpose
literally the same thing literally we
have this conversation on the show once
a week because we can't remember
separate that yeah
so Miss America the classy one yet Miss
America is talent and questions miss you
which I use Miss Congeniality miss us I
know she did a talent so much in America
okay
gracie lou freebush i love that movie
when she's like what something about her
interview she's like you know harsher
punishments and world peace yes she was
so good crazy [ __ ] is an icon of course
we already knew that though totally but
like I don't know I just I just love
Sandra but can I only wish good things
forever since her husband cheated on her
with Kat Von D right yes okay I think
that's not you don't Craig the Kat Von D
of the world like the house effect that
Kat from what I understand this is how
Kevin Dee shot developin see she was a
tattoo artists in Las Vegas hooked up
with Sandra Bullock's ex-husband very
nice husband was exposed as being the
cheater and then launched a success an
extremely successful makeup brand I
don't understand that like the
trajectory okay who's her agent here's
here's what it might be okay
Cavani tattoo artist in LA maybe like
making makeup at home and selling it on
Etsy scary big platform when she's
exposed as cheating with Jesse right
question Jesse James Decker they had the
same thing except I'm gonna be honest I
watched him on Celebrity Apprentice
because I'm preacher he was on Joan
Rivers season that's only when I watch
half past costs posthumously questions
like costume asleep but it was and
more Joan Rivers famine I need more Joan
Rivers content I never thought to watch
celebrity oh my god watch it really like
scratched an itch that I have your
costume asleep was she really right she
won that's why she's so Khloe
Kardashian's on that season Billy and
Andrew Dice Clay
they referenced him on comedians getting
coffee and I would only know who it is
because of Suburbia parent overhead well
anyways it's like very quite interesting
Claudia Jordan from ulema Atlanta she
gave Claudia's like such a bad name I
really don't like why I love her because
of oh really
um also some some playmate named Brandi
she did pretty good anyway
Jesse James oh yeah um but I like
understood what does he do for a living
and how did he get the motorcycle man
and he got Sandra both because she's
like a nice girl who just doesn't see I
love her does she have I was with again
no she adopted a child when she was in
New Orleans she does I think I mean when
celebrities don't live in like LA or
even New York like if you look of it if
you live in LA like you're shallow as a
separate if you live in New York that
you want someone 7 normalized but you
live literally anywhere else like you
just an arrogant person Kat Von D was on
Miami Ink and LA Ink for years so she
had at this platform she was like I feel
weird those were unknown tattoo artists
also wasn't like Pink's husband on that
show I don't know but just like to me
it's so weird how like you go from like
even though she had an audience she was
only some trashy reality show and then
was exposed as like a mistress and then
like was in Sephora like how do you get
into Sephora from just being a mistress
I don't know and it's like is this
makeup for mistresses also like I'm in
love with one of her lipsticks and
apparently her contour kits amazing but
like there are rumors that she's
anti-semitic
I just wanted like I know you're about
saying I totally where there's like
smoke there's not always fire and I know
I said that on the ivory I always said
where there's smoke there's fire and
I've learned that is just not true where
there's smoke sometimes there's just
someone yelling fire and there's not
actually one and so I don't like I've
been stuck with me before you say that
stuff I did and like there's just
apparently that she wrote to her Jewish
boss a note that was like something like
about Hitler but like there's a lot of
speculation that she didn't actually
write it so like I don't know I don't
know sometimes you have to give people
the benefit now we live in a culture
where like people on Twitter just can
label you whatever you want and like
everyone just and have seen your life
right yeah and take and just ruin your
life so I don't know I would
research before you say maybe I'll buy
kat von d palette yeah and I've been
like a literally like there's a lipstick
that's like us it's the perfect color
feeling I think literally Kylie's candy
K came inspired by this color it's
perfect it's something with the W I
don't remember the name and look I just
really like her stuff I never like
really explored it because I already
have so many Charlie can makeup that I
love and that I need and I can't just be
being like oh I'll try this for $35 and
$35 there were to be so I'm paying $400
yeah everything is $35 can I just say
though I went I went down a rabbit hole
of Olivia Jade who is like literally the
best makeup tutorials and I bought like
a bunch of her products from Sephora and
I the package arrived in like one thing
was this thing like it was so annoying
I called Sephora amazing customer
service because I always usually order
that stuff from Amazon I don't know why
I felt like ordering from Sephora they
had the most amazing customer service
lady in two seconds send me anything
like it was so fast I never miss a forum
on our service and they have an amazing
return policy and I'm not a big return
or like even when I don't like something
in the order online like I'll just wear
it instead of returning it because I
just hit San or turning stuff but with
makeup like with the foundation for
example you can't try that on in the
store other than on your hand so then
you go home and like wear it and take
pictures in it you don't know if you
like it they let you return anything
that has been used less than 50% of it
which is just like so gracious enemy
it's sober it's just for like how was
that economical for them because maybe
was young sent to make and a million
dollars so what are they do with like
the extra products I think they just
throw it away that's crazy
yeah but they they have those margins
yeah people don't know that so now
everyone go return everything just for
us yeah and now like I really I need to
great actually this is how it does that
work for a llanto I think so you just
have to show your receipt you probably
return it in store though but I think it
actually makes more sense because now I
only buy my makeup at Sephora so that I
have the option of returning it if I
don't like it so now I'm exclusive to
Sephora that's good I mean I'm exclusive
to amazon because it's so easy I have
the app and literally comes you can come
the same day it's crazy
look I bought literally like oh I bought
nail hardener cuz my nails are so
brittle my name is really over it oh I
got a good OPI one it came the same day
that I ordered it wait
Amazon screams creepy I know I'm getting
around deliver it I don't know I'm
obsessed with my Amazon like I literally
check the app more than I check
Instagram that's not true but similar
it's it's getting up there oh
from talking about Vanderpump rules to
this I will never know oh it looks let's
trace back
let's okay we're talking about banner
from hat Lundy Jesse James Miss
Congeniality Olivia culpo Raquel oh my
god I love tracing back on our time -
Wow we've been talking a mile a minute
for the past like 40 minutes like I
forgot that we're just in the studio
what a good show what a good show but
wait hold on we need to talk about the
other things that happened on Vanderpump
rules
oh right they still haven't figured out
that he said hang and not make mm-hmm
hang out not make out which like I just
I can't do a show until they Brittany
and Jax I really like Brittany that guy
Adam is so hot but like he's not right
for her no not at all and scheana
totally fabricated that whole thing but
I really enjoyed watching Jax like get
upset and angry over Brittany like I
think he needed that so scheana wasn't
wrong but she was being so annoying and
then like scheana and Katie yelling at
Jackson Brittany like like literally
it's Brittany refuses to speak for
herself so just like let them be yeah
and it's like maybe it's not the right
relationship for you but they like
seemed like when they have their moments
and they're just like in the car talking
and like laughing like I guess I see it
he'd like like not cheat on her
but other like this is me watching
scheana okay Madison parks Valletta like
I can't wait when she was talking to
Lisa and then she was telling Lisa what
she did to Jax like almost like waiting
for Lee's gonna be proud of her from
getting a relationship or trying to and
like they said was like no like two
wrongs do not make a right I cannot I
cannot with Robin Jeana wait but
actually I'm really enjoying watching
scheana tweet the shows because like
it's obviously very embarrassing first
she looks like a [ __ ] like they're not
even together now he's saying he doesn't
even love her and she's talking about
marriage and kids and I think hey
they're moving in together but how you
hey they're looking at houses how you
handle something like that like in the
afterwards it's like so important yeah
and she's just being like you guys like
I know like I'm sorry like I know thank
you for being cool that I when they're
gonna start filming probably soon ish
they always start in the spring summer
and they wonder how she's gonna behave
this season I feel like every season she
goes like hard for something and that's
just a personality but yeah that's kind
of cute like yeah on TV it just it
doesn't when they flashed back to her it
doesn't age well when they flush back to
her in Mike Shay being like my mom
always said marry first for money second
for love and I did the opposite and he's
like
I just like I long for the days of the
scheana Marie Shay but you know what it
makes scheana Shay was a savage she
didn't like a little more time you know
what it makes me think so like it makes
me think back to like the Eddie Cibrian
Brandi Glanville days and it's like
she's so marriage focused and like
relationship focus I'm so she doesn't
let her man not talk to her for a minute
so like how did she date someone who
doesn't let had a whole family and she
didn't even know Chucky she doesn't let
her man go to bodega make out with
people right he doesn't even make out
with me right so like that is so she is
so much tension and she's so
affectionate in like time consuming that
it's like but her man had a whole family
and right know also it's really
important to note like of all the things
I love when people on earth things about
the venom Emperor's cast like Stassi was
on American I mean no greatest for
amazing whatever it's called um they all
have like had these past lives she knows
on Jonas she also dated John Mayer which
is like my dream why yeah why I know why
do you think she's dating Robbie Hayes
now that's what people are saying I
thought so I have it then someone said
in our group that they saw scheana out
at Sur sitting with someone making out
with them and might have been Robbie but
it also couldn't chase I don't remember
who she said oh we should probably but
I'd love it they hung out at Sur they
look never hang out at Sur anymore and
it looks like the best night like they
probably got free drinks
yeah everyone like loves em wants to
take pictures of them it's probably so
much fun and did you see that Randall
and I'm it's Randall allow us to your
anniversary yeah cute I thought they
were announcing that they were engaged
I thought someone said they thought that
she was announcing that she was pregnant
because her belly's was face the other
way but I don't think so
no I think they're just cute and it was
a good way to like hide her man even
though we all know who her man is yeah
it's like stop hiding him we love Him we
love him we love I love them together I
don't even know him I know I'm just
anything well what does she wasn't in
the episode enough for me no but I feel
like next season is like Lala's season
it was really taken aback see Stassi
yeah yeah I wonder what if it's by
choice I think it's a little bit choice
also she was I think she was going
through a lot with Patrick like the
relationship and she didn't when I think
the spotlight on her yeah and she's like
letting everyone else be an [ __ ] now
she carried the show on her back for so
many years yeah well speaking of who
need to talk about Real Housewives of
Beverly Hills quickly it's on tonight
but something interesting that came
across our death oh very interesting I
don't know if this is true because I
don't have serious Brady
but apparently lisa rinna went on Andy
show which I'm not partied in true I
don't know
and she said that Lisa Vanderpump and
Kyle Richards get paid the most out of
the cast way more than she does way more
than anyone else and for that reason
she's not gonna bring all the drama and
do all of the work because she's not
getting paid equally which makes so much
sense
which makes so much is equal payday
right and this two minds because they do
have years are they were working they
were working overtime they took down
Adrienne they took down Taylor Armstrong
and then resurrected her they took down
Camille like they were working really
hard and now these are kind of their
golden years wait they can just you know
cashless look at let the younger ladies
think they can make like Ciara McCoy and
just like run to the bacons if you
morning in cash there they are McCoy
yeah that's yeah but Lisa Rinna works
very low hard like Teddy Mellencamp and
or some of these other and sorry house I
was like desserts okay so Lisa and Kyle
make the most tier one yeah
next here should be Erika Jayne and
arena but that's why both of them are
taking it back so yeah when people are
fighting both of them are like I don't
know getting involved cos I don't get
paid enough to do this
Erika Jayne should 100% be making the
same amount as Kyle no no because like
she didn't like it's just like when you
have a regular job like the more you
work for a company you get paid a raise
every day roots on the same level as
Kyle I mean as Lisa and she's worried
it's this is only dirt second season oh
yes he's still scrapping her way up it's
Erica's third it's Everly sorry but
Erika has three strong seasons under her
belt not even Julie's almost didn't come
back for a second year so like she's
she's scratching her way but that's why
she's working so hard she's doing and
then Teddy or jute and Teddy at the same
level Tori and Teddy Teddy is bringing
nothing no not only she did her first
season she brings literally nothing to
the table yeah is there another
housewife because that just should tell
us everything no that's a really I feel
like there's one more let me think let
me think let me think
does anyone know I think that's it maybe
no that's it that's doubling up okay so
yeah Teddy like not only is it her first
season she's not bringing the goods
except for like crying when Erica's meet
her and like I just so real why new
people come in and they're like I'm
gonna go after Erica it's two years in a
row
Jamie if you want to be smart let go
after Lisa Rinna because then Kyle and
Lisa Vanderpump alike rally behind you
right I mean I love Lisa right now I
don't like any what you against ever
like if you're wanting to be strategic
going after a fan favorite is the worst
thing you can do
we've learned that lots of it over you
teddy has not learned however when I
watch watch what happens I'd the polls
aren't on Erica side likely yeah when
they said who worried whose side are you
on like Teddy or Eric Oh some English it
like that
people said Teddy no yeah and Erica was
on watch what happens live or anything I
don't give a [ __ ] she didn't do anything
I know it's like when people but I like
my friends or people that I know like
take different sides than me in
housewives like arguments like it makes
me think less of them question
everything yeah been there are some
Housewives arguments that are ambiguous
and like I don't mind if you're on the
red okay so when I was in middle school
this was the hunter Reapers Erica last
season was confusing no totally t
America should enjoy anything wrong and
she was just like way too big for what
why but you know what who are we to
dictate some on this reaction I will
wave Erica Jane like I'm in a way of
course say listen when I was in becomes
a problem appreciate is when when Erica
was yelling at Eileen whose side are you
on
when I was in middle school it was chill
bursts Bethenny maybe I was like I was
about to get to high school it was Jill
bursts Bethenny and I was like so
invested I was hard core team what
people in the comments love Teddy what
our viewers now but you're getting why
let me say yeah I loved Hetty she's so
relatable I look Teddy - I prefer Teddy
over to read sad I like Teddy how
related she is ah okay Teddy seemed so
nice thirty
oh but the Camille is not we were
thinking of the seven that she's like
half Houseman right she was early I was
obsessed with Bethany verse jail I was
so hard core team Jill like you couldn't
tell me anything differently my friend
Rachel Herman was like hardcore teen
Bethany and I can meet like we think our
whole friendship we're hardcore jail in
the beginning I wasn't I was oh my god
but then like when she took it too far
at the Reunion absolutely does house
when she would refuse to see Tiffany
right and then like she overplayed her
hand because I think she was right in
the beginning of the argument and then
she like took it way too far away to see
never like started feeling bad for
Bethenny like cousins
shouldn't do anything yeah know what she
did was so smiled the punishment does
not fit the crowd in a way that
everything kind of like turned around I
like Bethenny's back on the show and
Bethenny's already successful it's just
like you really never know - to everyone
how the tables have turned everyone make
sure you're following for tuning in make
sure the following the morning shows on
Facebook Instagram YouTube and in the
podcast app we are working overtime to
beat felonious Florida number one an app
store we were number two yesterday like
let's just get to number one so
subscribe leave a review make sure you
subscribe to our YouTube page premium
content being turned out at all time and
becoming more and more premium every day
we are working if you guys have notes
questions comments concerns you know
where to reach us yes
we weren't free we work through the
people we're government we're civil
servants it has been a true pleasure
serving you today we will see you have a
wonderful day